happy monday today we're talking about
ps1 games showing up on ps5 as well as
eldon ring getting a co-op friendly mod
ps1 games have started to show up on psn
in malaysia and youtuber mystic dropped
a new video testing out the
functionality of classic games on a
modern console aka a playstation 5. in
the video mystic loads up odd world
abe's odyssey and shows off the game's
lack of support for the ps5's activity
cards before diving into the classics
menu that players are greeted with when
they press the options button in this
menu are rewind load and save and
settings rewind brings up a timeline of
frames beneath the menu that lets you
scroll backwards using the l2 to an
earlier point in the game mystic makes
the guess that each frame is about 10
seconds for load and save you can save
at any point in a system that is
separate from the one originally built
into the game however the original save
system is still usable as the game
thinks there is a memory card inserted
lastly there are visual presets in the
settings menu as well as the ability to
change the game's aspect ratio these
presets include default which is sharp
bright and colorful retro classic which
is less sharp and much darker and modern
a mix of the two that consists of a
sharper image like default but is just
as dark as retro i highly recommend you
check out the full video and i'll have
it linked in the description but okay
over in the lens between lies a new mod
in progress that looks to make coop a
much easier process last week luke yui
on youtube dropped a trailer for an
elden ring seamless co-op mode that they
say quote removes all multiplayer
boundaries and allows for connections to
persist after death for starters the mod
lets friends ride horses together a
feature that vanilla elden ring co-op
really needs so that i can race my
friends to the next battle in style the
next is shared rewards so that you can
feel like you're playing borderlands
between get it
thank you thank you but maybe you didn't
quite make it to the end of the fight
alive well the mod also adds a spectator
cam so you can watch your friend carry
you to victory luke said the public beta
of the mod will be available on may 27th
on nexus mods so mark your calendar if
this interests you now let's talk about
call of duty's mid-season 3 update
warzone will be getting a new mode
called champion of caldera in this
limited time solo mode 150 players will
compete against each other and a single
continuously closing circle all players
will drop in with their custom loadout a
gas mask and a single redeploy
extraction token additionally kills in
this mode immediately refill the
player's health ammo and equipment
incentivizing players to play
aggressively one of the main changes
coming with warzone's mid-season update
is the new fast travel system on caldera
the new underground transit system will
feature 14 access points indicated on
the warzone tack map and minimap by a
silver vault door symbol this update
will go live on may 25th for warzone at
9am pacific 12pm eastern and for
vanguard at 10 am pacific 1pm eastern
for even more information on the
mid-season changes head over to
gamespot.com or check the link in the
description and before we close out just
a reminder that today may 23rd is the
cutoff for using a credit card to add
funds to your nintendo account through
the wii u or 3ds eshop the next deadline
for these eshops is in august so remind
me to remind you when that rolls around
thanks for watching and i'll see you
tomorrow
[Music]